et ça bonjour merci d'être en direct sur
rt france ryad a donc annoncé un plan
d'austérité rendues nécessaires par la
forte baisse de la demande d'or noir
dans le reste du monde
ces mesures peuvent elles suscité un
certain mécontentement de l'opinion
publique à votre avis oui je crois que
les réseaux sociaux d'ailleurs sont
assez révélateur de l'état d'esprit au
des expressions de critiques si vous
voulez à l'égard de du régime se sont
manifestés et il faut penser que les
saoudiens ont été des enfants gâtés
puisqu'ils vont faire à monsieur raison
vu l'électricité qui était gratuite
devenir payante la tva à paraître et on
a emmené mes intuitions d'entrer dans
une espèce de normes internationales et
évidemment avec la baisse et
l'effondrement des prix du pétrole ne
provoquait pas la compétition avec la
russie les états-unis thé avec le co
vide là les ressources de l'état
saoudien se sont écroulés donc
effectivement sur mauvais jour qui seul
qui sape qui s'annonce à l'horizon
dernière chose il ya eu une vague
d'arrestations dans l'entourage du
pouvoir aussi ce qui prouve que même à
l'intérieur de la famille royale
vous avez des gens qui trouvent que le
pouvoir de mohammed bin salman est
devenu excessif et que sa politique
n'est pas bonne alors on sait que
l'arabie saoudite prévoit d'emprunter
près de 60 milliards de dollars sur
l'année 1 pour financer ses déficits
budgétaires
le pays a longtemps été excédentaire le
budget de l'état a constamment était
dans le rouge depuis 2014
comment l'expliquer je crois que si vous
voulez c'est un pays qui vit au dessus
de ses moyens et qui est mono
producteurs c'est-à-dire que les
rentrées pétrolières représentent 90% de
son de son pipe et puis l'autre
ressources et le pèlerinage et je vous
ferai remarquer que pour le pèlerinage
mois la douane salmane a interdit le
petit pèlerinage
ce qui laisse penser qu'effectivement
l'arabie saoudite crois pas non plus à
la protection médicale qu'à la
protection divine si vous voulez ce qui
est quand même un choc pour ce pays qui
se prétendait le leader du monde arabe
qui a soutenu un peu tous les propos
incroyable sur le fait que la le coville
été envoyées cette étude punition divine
bref donc ça je laisse de côté mais vous
avez des deux ressources qui vont
s'écrouler en même temps
et donc évidemment à part des mesures
budgétaires a dit on pas d'emprunt
l'arabie saoudite reste un bon risque
c'est une évidence mais c'est un bon
risque dans des conditions sociales qui
encore une fois sont empreintes de ce
bouleversant et dont on ne sait comment
elle sera gérée par la société
saoudienne
quand on en arrive à tripler la tva d'un
seul coup et à suspendre le versement
des allocations de vie chère mais on est
vraiment face à une situation qui est
tout à fait nouvelle pour la société
somodia et il reste pardon encore une
fois la crise la guerre au yémen dont
mohammed bin salman n'arrive pas à se
défaire
la guerre se poursuit elles coûtent cher
et donc on a tous les facteurs qui se
conjuguent au mars on sait que ryad a
également augmenté sa production et
abaisser le coût de la livraison pour
ses clients d'or noir dans l'espoir de
préserver justement ses parts de marché
ce que cette stratégie de diviser le
cours du pétrole par trois et est bien
s'est révélé être un échec pour ryad
le ciel est un échec pour tous les pays
producteurs simplement l'arabie saoudite
qu'elle celui qui est le plus dépendant
des ressources pétrolières donc c'est
évidemment celui qui risque le plus
facilement d'être atteint par cette
espèce de stratégie du pire
je fais remarquer quand même aussi des
états unis sont terriblement affecté
également parce que tous leurs
producteurs de pétrole de gaz de schiste
si vous les sons sont des petits
producteurs et qui ferme qui file tory
parce en faillite si vous voulez à
chaque fois que le prix du pétrole
s'écroule
donc on est face à deux pays qui ont des
situations sociales très différentes
mais l'arabie saoudite est évidemment
dans la situation sociale et économique
la pire pas par rapport à l'effondrement
des prix du pétrole et à sa merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes ancien haut
fonctionnaire du ministère de la défense